ما هذا
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مساء الخير على حضراتكم يا رب
تكونوا باتم صحه وسلامه انتم سمعتوا
المزيكا اللي تسربت التسريبات بتاعه ماندو
مزيكا ام كلثوم ان شاء الله تكون السهر
ممتعه زي موسيقى ام كلثوم يعني انا كنت
عاوز اقول حاجه لكن الاسئله جاءت تباعا
المفروض ان كان موضوعنا النهارده الاساسي
احنا بنتكلم على مجموعه الموضوعات اللي
انت اخترتوها اللي هي كواليس التطبيع مع
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
عندنا الانتخابات التركيه
وتطورات الاوضاع الاقتصاديه بصفه عامه
العالميه وانعكاساتها على المنطقه ولكن
طبعا جدت مستجدات الوضع متفجر في فلسطين
وفي السودان
نبذ القصاره جهنئ ان شاء الله السؤال
الاولاني من اخوان علي هل ايران تدعم
البوليساريو هي المغرب اتهمتها بذلك
فالاتهام المغرب انها الايران دعمت
البوليساريو ولذلك قررت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
يعني من تعده سنوات قطع العلاقات مع
المغرب واتهمت بشار الاسد بنفس التهمه
يعني
اتفقت روسيا مع الهند على التبادل بالعمله
المحليه
فتراكمت الروبيه لدى روسيا بسبب شراء
النفط الان تطلب روسيا الاعتماد على سله
عملات هل هذا معناه عدم وجود بديل للدولار
ده محمد ما هي محمد هي دي القضيه اللي هي
واحده من اهم القضايا اللي شاغله كتير من
دول العالم
خلاصه القصه انه العالم كان مرتاح
لاعتماد على الدولار حتى وان كرهوه لانه
هو كان
البديل المقبول لكل دول العالم
بسبب قوه الصين وبسبب العداء المستمر مع
روسيا وبسبب معاداه الولايات المتحده
للصين وروسيا وبسبب قلق الدول الاخرى ان
الولايات المتحده يمكن ان تفعل الدولار
كوسيله للعقاب اذا وقعت في خلاف معهم ولو
انتم عاوزين التفاصيل انا تحت امركم في
ازاي هي بتستخدم الدولار لمعاقبه الدول
الاخرى ابتدوا يبحثوا عن بدائل البدائل
حتى الان يعني كثيره مقترحات لم تنضج بعد
بعدها بيحاول يبحث عن مثلا
سله من العملات زي ما انت حضرتك قلت
ودي لها برضو قصه يعني اذا
يعني طرحت ما زال من الاسئله اقول لكم ايه
المقصود بكلمه سله عملات بعضهم بيحاول
يتوسع في استخدام العملات المتبادله يعني
مثلا نموذج اللي انت اشرت اليه
ان الهند تاخد عملات تشتري بعملتها
المحليه وروسيا تشتري من عملتها المحليه
والنموذج ده ما زال تحت الدراسه هو بينجح
لو كانت المساله محسوبه يعني لو تخيلت
مثلا انه
الهند بتشتري دولار بتشتري بترول مثلا او
سلع روسيه بما يعادل عشره مليار دولار من
روسيا وروسيا بتشتري سلع من الهند بما
يعادل 5 مليار دولار روسيا فالبلد دي
بتحاول ان هي تقبل العمله
الهنديه في حدود الخمسه مليار تحتفظ بها
وتعيد شراء السلع والهند بتقبل ما يعادل
العشره مليار دولار
من الروبل الروسي بيقعد العشره مليار
دولار من الروبل الروسي ويتم التبادل
والفكره ما زالت قيد الدراسه
لماذا لا تمانع الدول الخليج الوجود
الامريكي وتكره الوجود الايراني علي
طبعا يا علي يعني
هي الحساسيات ما بين دول الجوار بدايه ما
هياش قاصره على الخليج ودول وايران معظم
الدول المتجاوره بيكون بينها حساسيات اكثر
من الحساسيات بين الدول اللي بتبعد بينهم
مسافات طويله طبعا الامثله بقى يعني يعني
مثلا علاقه الصين بينا هنا ايه علاقه طيبه
جيده ما فيش مشاكل او ما فيش علاقه بين
اصله قبل ما يكون في النهضه الصينيه ديت
انما تخيل بقى وضع الدول المجاوره للصين
هل هتكون بنفس الود خايفه مرتبكه مضطره
للتحالف معها من باب الخوف مضطره
فالقرب
الحدود دايما بيخلق حساسيات في الغالب
يعني فده مش امر غريب لكن اجابه على
سؤال حضرتك بالتفصيل الولايات المتحده
ودول الخليج بدات علاقه تحالف
وانتفاع متبادل كانت بريطانيا اولا ثم
جاءت الولايات المتحده وكانت العلاقه
قائمه على كده انا كدوله كبرى والدول
الخليج كانت دول صغيره ناشئه سوف اكفل لكم
الامن من اي طامع فيكم في مقابل وطبعا
هساعدكم في الحصول على تكنولوجيا متطوره
الى اخره في مقابل انه انا اضع قواعد
العسكريه اللي هي طبعا علشان كوسيله
لحمايه هذه الدول وتحقيق الامن لها في
مقابل انه انا احصل على البترول بانتظام
وبعد ما تدون البترول بانتظام سوف تحصلون
مني على دولار وسوف تحصلون على عوائد من
دول اخرى يفضل ان تستثمروا هذه الاموال في
اقراض الحكومه الامريكيه وهذا هو ما يسمى
وتحديدا من بعد عام 1971 من بعد عام 1974
فكان وجود الامريكي مرحب به من جانب الدول
الخليج بصفه عامه انما ايران قصه اخرى
تنافس قديم حساسيات كبيره مثلا دوله زي
البحرين كانت خرجت من استقلت عن مين
استقلت عن عن موقعنا الخيار بعد خروج
البريطانيين سنه 71
انه عملوا استفتاء يعني بعد ما خرجت من
المنطقه انه اتفقوا مع الايرانيين مفردات
ما بين ايران والبريطانيين على مصير
البحرين يا رب تقول هذه ارض اريد ان
استردها والبحرينيين بارود بيقولوا نريد
ان نكون دوله مستقله يعني من حوالي خمسين
سنه كان في خلاف ما بين البحرين اللي هي
لم تكن دوله اعلنت حتى هذه اللحظه وما بين
البحر وما بين الايران احنا دوله احنا جزء
من ايران ولا لا تريدون ان تكونوا جزءا من
ايران ام لا الكلام ده لم ينتهي هو
[موسيقى]
وضع طبيعي
ام ار بيقول او مستر بيقول قبول العرب
عوده سوريا مكرهين فقط بسبب ملف المخدرات
لان هذا الملف المداوم مدمر وسوف تدفع دول
الخليج للنظام الخمسه مليار دولار
مورد انداره النظام للملفات القذره هذا
مذل
وحاجه كده يعني هذا مذهل ويدرس اه يعني
يقصد ان دي حاجه مذهله انه النظام ينجح
انه بشار الاسد ينجح في استعاده العلاقات
دول عربيه عشان ملف المخدرات يعني انا
مختلف معك هو المساله ما كانتش قائمه على
المخدرات وطبعا ام ار بي يشير الى انه في
السنوات الاخيره نشاط
تجاره المخدرات او تحديدا عقار اسمه
الكبتاجون لما سالت عن الكبتاجون قالوا لي
عقار مصنع من ماده معروفه كيميائيه ويسبب
الادمان وانه بيصدر منه اطنان كثيره لدول
الجوار وبيضر ارباح كبيره الارقام متباينه
طبعا لان هي مش سلعه معروفه يعني صادرات
ووردات لكن مليارات الدولارات ده عامل
ازعج دول الجوار وكان احد العوامل اللي
دفعت دول الجوار للتفاوض مع بشار الاسد
لكنه ليس العامل الوحيد العوامل متعدده
وفي حلقه اخيره اتكلمنا عنها كواليس
التطبيع مع بشار الاسد استاذنكم ان تعودوا
اليها انما الحقيقه اسباب متعدده وليس فقط
مخدر الكبتاجون الدول العربيه ادركت بعد
فتره انه مش معقوله هنفضل مش دول العربيه
الدول العربيه ما انت عندك تركيا كمان نفس
القصه ادركوا انه مش هيفضلوا يعني من غير
المنطقي ان تظل في حاله خ مع بشار الاسد
وتعاديه بعد ان اصبح امرا واقعا واستطاع
بدعم روسيا
وايران ان ينتصر ويبقى ويسيطر على معظم
مساحه سوريا وانت عندك علاقات اي دوله
عندها مصالح مع سوريا يعني
بقطع النظر عن من يحكمها لان هم مش
هيقدروا يستغنوا عن دوله في سوريا واذا
تركوا سوريا حتى لو هم استغنوا عن اي
مصالح لهم مستثمرات سوريا لن تتركهم ومثال
الكبتاجون يعني حاله تثبت ذلك هم بقى
عاوزين اكثر من التفاوض على الكبتاجون
تسويه للوضع السوري بشكل كامل مش عاوز
اطول على حضرتك اكتر من كده في الاجابه
الاجابه اظن في الحلقه الاخيره اللي هي
بعنوان لماذا تقود المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التطبيع مع بشار الاسد الذي
تكرهه بس هو الحلقه بتتكلم ميل عن المملكه
لكن بتتكلم عن مواقف الدول العربيه الاخرى
استاذ سيد حسب اطلاعك على التاريخ هل يوجد
شعب قامه 90% منه بثوره على